so we're given a series here and they
say what series should we use in the
limit comparison test let me underline
that the limit comparison test in order
to determine whether s converges so
let's just remind ourselves about the
limit comparison test if we say if we
say that we have two series and I'll
just use this notation a sub N and then
another series B sub N and we know that
a sub N and B sub n are greater than or
equal to 0 for all n for all n if we
know this then if then if the limit as n
approaches infinity of a sub n over B
sub n is equal to some positive constant
so 0 is less than that constant is less
than infinity then either both converge
then both converge both converge both
converge or both diverge both diverge
and it really makes a lot of sense
because it's saying look as we get into
our really large values of n as we go
really far out there in terms of the
terms if our behavior starts to look the
same then it makes sense that both these
series would converge or diverge and we
have an introductory visio we have an
introductory video on this in another
video so let's think about who what if
we say that this is our a sub n if we
say that this is a sub n right over here
what is the series that we can really
compare to that seems to have the same
behavior as n gets really large well
this one gets to seems to gets unbounded
this one doesn't look that similar has a
3 to the N minus 1 in the denominator
but the numerator doesn't behave the
same this one over here is interesting
because we could write this this is the
same thing as the sum N equals 1 to
infinity we could write this as 2 to the
N over 3 to the N and these are very
similar the only difference between this
and this is that in the denominator here
or in the denominator up here we
have a minus 1 and down here we don't
have that minus one and so it makes
sense given that that's just a constant
that as n gets very large that these
might behave the same so let's try it
out let's find the limit and we also
know that the a sub NS and the V sub
ends if we say that this right over here
is V sub n we say that's B sub n that
this is going to be positive or this is
gonna be greater than or equal to 0 for
N equals 1 to 3 so for any values this
is going to be greater than or equal to
0 and the same thing right over here
it's going to be greater than or equal
to 0 for all the ends that we care about
so we meet these these first constraints
and so let's find the limit as n
approaches infinity of a sub n which is
I'll write in that red color which is 2
to the nth power over 3 to the n minus 1
over B sub n over 2 to the N over 3 to
the N so let me actually do do a little
algebraic manipulation right over here
this is going to be the same thing as 2
to the N over 3 to the n minus 1 times
times 3 to the N over 2 to the N divided
the numerator and denominators by 2 to
the N those cancel out and so this will
give us this will give us 3 to the N
over 3 to the N minus 1 agree we can
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 3 to the N and that'll give us 1 over
1 minus 1 over 3 to the N so we could
say this is the same thing as the limit
as n approaches infinity of 1 over 1
minus 1 over 3 to the N well what's this
going to be equal to well as n
approaches infinity this thing 1 over 3
to the N that's going to go to 0 so this
is this whole thing is just going to
approach 1 and one is clearly between 0
and infinity so the destinies of these
two series are tie they either both
converge or they both diverge and so
this is a good one to use the limit
comparison test with and so let's think
about it do they
either both converge or do they both
diverge well this is a geometric series
our common ratio here is less than 1 so
this is going to converge this is going
to converge and because this one
converges by the limit comparison test
our original series s converges
converges and we are done